Kevin Allen of USA Today the NHL
columnist an NHL insider joining me here
on the show how are you Kevin
doing a great rich thanks okay so walk
me through why this happened well I mean
it was talked about for most of the
season it was just expected that this
would be Barry trotters last season the
there appeared to be a fracture between
management and an trots you know we
found as we've just recently found out
he had a contact a contract extension
but only if he won the Cup and I think
that was the issue when we got to the
end here his associate coach Reardon has
a contract extension it looked like the
Capitals were preparing for life without
trots but when the season was over trots
did say you know I want to be back and
everybody went hmm well you know maybe
they can figure it out and the other
issue here and this is an important one
since very tried signed his contract the
price of poker for coaches has gone way
up and now you know the top coach
Babcock has paid six point two five
million and Joel Quenneville and
Chicago's at six million and Claude
Julien the Montreal's at five nine and
the extension that Trott's had on this
contract would be for a 1.5 we made
before that a modest increase believed
to be about 300,000 so I was 1.8 million
so I'm sure if the Capitals would have
said we'll pay you in the neighborhood
of all the other top coaches he probably
would have stayed but they apparently
didn't want to do that they wanted to
stick by the original contract and to me
you know the fact that they didn't
extend him before said that they were
sort of ready to move on and for
whatever reason and I I think it was
sort of a respect issue for berry trots
why didn't they extend them a year ago
and when we got to this point they find
he said well you know we've been
preparing for this I guess we're ready
to go and Trust of course won't be out
of work all that long I mean there's not
a lot of bacon sees but whenever there
is one he's gonna be the favorite
together what about long for the island
impossible I mean that's Lulu amaryllis
history to take the high profile coaches
but you know I don't know how far into
the process Lou is you know has he
already
you know I have someone in mind so I
don't know where we are on that sort of
toothbrush but you know it's also not
out of the realm of possibility that the
gym will look and say hey my guys on the
bubble you know he may be in trouble
next fall maybe I'll pull the trigger
now that could happen as well but you
know wouldn't be the worst thing for
berry tribes just to you know have a
nice summer wait till the fall because
somebody would get fired you know we're
not going to have another season like we
have this year what no what it got fired
and he'll be right there sort of waiting
in the wings and last time when he got
fired by Nashville he signed immediately
and really didn't have any time off and
so probably wouldn't be the end of the
world training me there because he you
know he's a hot free agent right now
like he is so well respected with an eye
well Kevin Allen the USA Today here look
I understand I'm you know that many
people in the sports management world
including the TV sports management world
their leverage junkies if they have the
leverage they're gonna exact it if they
don't have it they'll seek it out but
isn't there some form of payment that
could be had outside of the leverage
world based on the fact that you just
look around and see how the entire
community is nuts about the Washington
Capitals and keeping the gang together
isn't there some value in that well I
would think so I mean you know if you're
asking me if this is the public
relations problem for the Capitals I say
yes you know I mean he was an important
part of that team and I think the
players understood like the players are
the real losers here like you know I
mean that the Capitals the team will
survive and and Trott's will get a great
job elsewhere but you know the players
sort of understood that trot sort of
brought them together sure it was the
players who want the top and it was the
Ovechkin and crews now thought they
carried them but you know he had a way
to bring them all together and there was
a lot of changes to this team you know a
third of the roster was turned over from
the previous season and he sort of
figured out how to get them all on the
same page and took a while like they
struggled for a lot of the season and
then late in the season they kind of
came together and you could sense during
the playoffs just the way Ovechkin spoke
that he understood that that trots was
playing a role in this and that there
was something
special about the chemistry that
everybody had together including the
code so you know I was the guy if they
do indeed give the job to weird and you
know he's under tremendous pressure
because how do you duplicate you know
what the capitals you know did this
season like it was gonna be hard enough
with trots there and now boy it's the
same as a bomb yeah and then you got the
Western Conference populist like you've
already set the bar pretty high one year
in with with with bogus right I mean was
the worst job in all of sports will be
the general manager of the Seattle
expansion theme like how do you follow
up what George McPhee did in Las Vegas
like there's just no possible way
because hey the gyms around the league
now are smarter about this the new
expansion process so you know they're
not gonna you know give up to players to
save one like they did before was they
just to allow Vegas to kind of a
cumulate a really nice roster I I pity
the poor general manager the Seattle
expansion teams and it won't be coming
down the pike here pretty quick so would
it be so if I I want to just say maybe
the NHL's on a roll let's take Seattle
in next year's what Western Conference
championship right the against against
let's hold him in the Maple Leafs right
they've been waiting a long time just
like the caps let's go let's go Leafs
Seattle next year what do you think
about that well I think it would
certainly create a lot of attention and
because you know there are a lot of
conspiracy nuts out there who think that
the NHL set up the big is called a nice
to go all the way to does come from the
David Stern family right I mean the
sports management I and and I will say
this you know I think you know we hope
we know how long David Stern staying at
the MA I predict Gary Bettman is gonna
go longer then David Stern when at the
NBA I you know he's been great health
he's 66 he's gonna go into this mid
seventies that's Kevin Allen of USA
Today all right the story of Mike
Hoffman for those who might not know
because they're not paying attention to
what's going on in Ottawa
can you lay it out what what i down here
with my Kaufman and the Ottawa Senators
and why he's uh why he was traded Kevin
yeah I mean it's it's it's pretty simple
really I mean mark Hoffman's fiancee was
accused by Eric Carlson's wife of
harassing her on social media making
some very very derogatory you know
comments about her some really hideous
comments under a pseudonym and you know
basically it's come out she has four in
the Canadian version of a protection
order from from her and apparently
that's been going on for a while and so
now the question is is why did the
Senators nip this in the bud a lot
earlier it was pretty clear when this
all came out that Austin was going to
have to be traded and so today he was
traded to the San Jose Sharks but the
Sharks really didn't wanna they just
wanted to flip him to the Florida
Panthers because the Panthers and the
Senators couldn't agree upon a deal but
they wanted to give up draft picks the
Sharks wanted draft picks they wanted to
get rid of Michael Bakr who is not the
same level of player that Hoffman is but
often obviously has been devalued by as
a controversy so the Senators lose in
terms of they didn't get full value for
Hoffman the Panthers believe they
desperately needed offense they get a
four time twenty goal scorers score 20
or more and the big winner of course is
the Sharks to clear up a bunch of cap
space and get four draft picks for
getting rid of a guy that you know they
can live without in Michael Bachman well
I mean so I guess the the question is
you've got the captain of the Ottawa
Senators accusing my Kaufman's fiance of
cyber stalking and how will that sit in
the Panthers locker room well it's it's
interesting I mean Dale Talan said on
the conference call that you know that's
behind us but you know we all know there
are a lot of friends throughout the
National Hockey League so there you know
there could be some issues but I also
think that players are you know they're
all about winning and it all will be
forgotten
Hoffman produces and if the team is
better than with him
on it than than with him not on it so
you know I think probably the fact that
he's not in Ottawa where they were
clearly would have been problems you
know even though Eric Cartman Carlson is
likely to be traded to not because of
this but because you know he's not
likely to be resigned next year senators
don't really want to pay him more than
ten million dollars so they may trade
him this week as well so both players
could end up being on different teams
Kevin appreciate the time we'll chat
throughout the offseason and then when
puck drops we'll reach out again thanks
to the time that's Kevin Allen of USA
Today the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience